[Music]
whoever you found is not my boy guess
i'm removing a sin straight out of the
gate joyce's reaction to her experience
with the christmas lights the demogorgon
coming through the wall and then moments
later hearing about will's body being
found is the perfect balance of frantic
terrified and hopeful when none is
pulling off a top-notch performance in
this series i'm here for it he was
talking with this
talking that feeling when as a viewer
you know the wild rambling is true but
all the characters in the story
rightfully think the wild rambling is
just wild rambling because it sounds
well wild while this does a great job of
putting you in the shoes of the same
character it just doesn't feel good the
bright light over their heads is a
reminder that the house does in fact
have electricity joyce can't afford
cigarettes but she can afford the
expensive light bulb with selective
electric currents that scan the room and
amplify dramatic tension or maybe the
lack of lighting is a tactic to attempt
to hide the chaos clutter in the house
no i'm not blaming the people for the
mess it's the bulb's fault for giving
them that if you don't see it you don't
have to deal with it vibe [ __ ]
stranger things bulb man
okay last mention of the lighting
situation but it's pretty clear from the
light streaming in from the bathroom
window that when joyce was outside she
should have been blinded by whatever
bulb is attempting to mimic the [ __ ]
sun blind i thought we were friends you
know my friends tell each other the
truth kids are so dumb they blame
everyone else for their own inability to
process and manage emotions and let
downs super glad we grow out of that
phase as we age what you did sucks lucas
was right about you not only does mike
survive saying this to a person who can
snap next with their mind but he also
does not immediately apologize when he
finds out that eleven was telling the
truth even though he now knows that it
was him being the [ __ ] all along you
know maybe i've been focused on the lack
of first names for too long now maybe
maybe the names are actually a hidden
secret message just waiting to be found
oh sh
what does it mean i can stop by the
video store on the way back pick out
whatever you want even r-rated yes
because the thing a grieving kid needs
to have is a good old jolt of r-rated
adrenaline i guess i should need another
reminder that we're in the 80s when
parents didn't give a [ __ ] about scaring
their little ones for life by inviting a
boy and his dog into the subconscious
lucas do you copy i'm surprised that he
eventually does copy the antennas on
these old radios fully extended would be
like four feet long so while i'm not
saying that mike and lucas wouldn't have
any reception at these links the show is
still definitely overlooking the one
situation where size does matter
i guess some two-way radios will allow
the other person to cut in which totally
eliminates the need for over and out
which is clearly the coolest part of
communicating in this way also why are
these two fully dressed and already back
in bed you mean about his funeral
no not his funeral screw his funeral i'm
surprised to screw his funeral works and
getting lucas to comply with his request
but i'm even more surprised mike didn't
say that he has some new evidence that
will is alive instead of keeping him in
suspense using this muted color palette
at a coroner's office just because the
people are dead doesn't mean your sense
of style has to be he has a birthmark on
his right arm can you show that to me
please you know what this show never
does it never shows us the birthmark on
the will doll if there's no birthmark on
his arm then everyone should be
suspicious of this doppler will if there
is a birthmark on whippleganger well my
sinful question is simply how how did
the [ __ ] from state know about
will's birthmark was his body scanned by
someone before he popped into the
underbelly of pg horror what the [ __ ] is
the hawkins police badge's symbol anyway
it's like the department had to
compromise with the person who wanted a
dangerous looking weapon and a nature
lover obsessed with dandelions
yelling angrily at a woman who was just
asked to identify the body of her son
when you talk to the cops just
don't mention the beers thinking anyone
cares about the beers in a town with an
ever-increasing missing person problem
has got to be the prototypical teenage
boy equivalent of eating an apple
because this scene doesn't move the plot
forward as much as it paints steve as an
[ __ ] i know it sounds crazy i i i
sound crazy you think i don't know that
it is crazy word-for-word dialogue of me
explaining why michael bay's remake of
ambulance is a modern-day masterpiece
makes it into the show i am not gonna
stop looking for him until i find him
and bring him home
i am going to bring him home no offense
mom but choice is not my mom trying to
find a way to bring me back from a dark
dimension in this scene where is a lie i
see we have the ever annoying shout the
absurd truth that no one believes until
they believe you cliche at play here
there's no way we're gonna get the
weirdo in there without anyone noticing
i mean
look at her i know it was the 80s and
gender stereotypes were all the rage but
this need to make 11 look pretty in pink
seems more about cramming in your homage
to e.t than it is about anyone actually
being concerned with her appearance you
know how when you drive a car at night
with the interior lights on it can [ __ ]
with some of your vision this helmet is
giving me those vibes they're high beams
hugging his cheekbones and lighting up
the entirety of his field of vision what
the [ __ ] use is that it helps us see him
but i highly doubt he can see much
further than a few feet in front of him
unless this was designed for us to see
every one of his pores in which case the
helmet lights are great matthew
million's hair is finally covered in
this scene good luck in there son miss
redshirt thinks he's going to survive
this and kurtz's life
was running swiftly too nancy wheeler mr
stroupel muffin doesn't respond to this
interruption with what the [ __ ]
principal pumpkin scruffle it's hard
enough teaching joseph conrad to these
insolent little sh without you busting
in here like the tater flip and kool-aid
man the school's decision to keep score
at will's memorial assembly may be the
strangest thing in this episode i'm
no
you're not not listening to the person
you're accusing of not listening while
they are actively listening this show
has set a standard that all lamps in the
kids rooms must be on and i'm suddenly
very upset that this lamp isn't on no
one will be seated as nancy stitches
together a picture with an important
detail that's located on an intact
portion that does not need to be
stitched together at all the show wants
us to believe that when nancy hastily
picked up some of these ripped up
pictures in the previous episode she
managed to get all the pieces needed to
put this one of barb completely back
together and i want to believe that one
of the writers definitely pulled this
out of their upside down also taping the
top of the picture rather than the back
of the picture
but slowly like super slow my yelling
may make it seem like reeling him in is
urgent but just you know really take
your time will was an exceptional
student
and a wonderful friend to all of us i
believe will is a good kid and even an
exceptional student but there's no way
he had time to be friends with the whole
school let alone be a wonderful one look
at these
fakers they probably didn't even know
his name till today faking what these
expressions of boredom every one of
these kids was forced to be at this
assembly just like you so just slow down
there with the judgments boys it's kids
who circle the entire gymnasium to get a
better view of a fight that grow up to
cause a long slow down on the freeway
because they can't avoid looking at the
accident just [ __ ] go didn't you
listen to the counselor wheeler grief
shows herself in funny ways riders don't
realize the potential of their funny
ways spin-off
and one cent for me because perfect
stranger things was there the entire
time
we all want to think that troy pissed
himself out of fear but deep down we're
all pretty sure eleven used some sort of
telekinetic catheter to force pee from
this poor kid's bladder and while we all
hate troy i don't believe we'd wish this
on our greatest enemy hey what's going
on here principal coleman says this 15
seconds after the laughing began
30 seconds after troy's death threat
you're dead wheeled in almost a full
minute after the entire gymnasium began
to go silent when any seasoned school
admin would know that this many kids
being quiet is a telltale sign that the
proverbial pudding cup is about to hit
the overhead projector i don't know what
your budget is but over here we we have
copper and bronze selling things to
grieving people your mom um
she said you'd be here stalking he
didn't have a face i need to address the
elephant in this episode he didn't have
a face but he had no face this refusal
to ask the important questions like did
it have eyes and does it have human
grace deprived us all of the painfully
appropriate billy idol b plot we all
wanted and me personally of the
opportunity to say les you son visage
cliche
[Music]
ah yes july 15 2016. the day google saw
a spike of interest in tooth pain and
double down on adds to dentistry
nationwide suckers whoop the hair is
back she's finding them this is crazy
calm down she just closed her eyes sure
we as the viewers know she's locating
will right now but mike and dustin do
jump to conclusions way too often and
lucas really doesn't get enough credit
for his insistence on empirical evidence
what is that
seems about 10 years too early but i'm
pretty sure it's the first track off the
upside downward spiral
when joyce tears the wallpaper and sees
will on the other side she doesn't
immediately get the axe and try to break
through the wall i know it can't work
for story reasons but not even trying
until it's obviously too late leaves
open the possibility that it could have
worked and makes this seem very
frustrating to watch i applaud him for
being proactive and attempting to subdue
the flames but dustin is shooting the
front of the radio with the extinguisher
when the back is obviously on fire my
vintage stereo receiver once suffered a
similar fate as the heath kit and while
i chose instead to flee with my life i
found my knowledge of the flame's
location very helpful in my hasty
retreat given the time period there's
most likely asbestos somewhere in that
wall and this type of demolition is a
big no-no stephen king is staring right
into the camera in this scene part of me
loves hopper part of me is angry that he
doesn't drag the out-cold body of the
state trooper into the room so his
shenanigans aren't easily noticed i'd be
so good at covering up crimes wait
hopper's about to find out that this is
some kind of jim henson muppet version
of will and while the surprise isn't
completely lost on me i have to say that
even a casual fan of csi miami would
have been made suspicious by the lack of
hawaii incision and i'm not saying that
i know anything about actual autopsies
but if the shadow we grew behind the
cover-up was more detail-oriented they
could have fooled me for at least a
couple more seconds in my shadowy group
i of course mean uriah and voltaire
duffer also we're all glad that he cuts
into the will doll because it gives us
some closure that all of this isn't in
joyce's head but go with me here how do
we know that stuffing bodies with
stuffing isn't just a normal thing that
happens like does anyone ever double
check that this is abnormal all we want
right now is for hopper to tell joyce
that he checked the body and believes
her but instead we get lonnie
faces are for no one you are still
someone and to someone
the faces are as good as poison
no matter what
you got
i don't work with o'bannon i feel bad
and i meant
drop you
well it all seemed a bit over the top to
me considering
considering what never like him i never
trust her here for all i know he had me
set up and had my friend angel fernandez
killed okay just when you talk to the
cops just tell them i hate them listen
part of the day you're around the corner
right here on first avenue mr charlie's
is the name of the place it's the name
of the guy behind the counter and tell
him mr charlie sent you and he'll sell
you cigarettes
roger that
dude you don't have to do the k sound it
already does that out copy that i'm not
going to make the sound after i say
stuff from now on
jd mcnugget over and out
that was the last one
is that a load-bearing wall oh man i
hope not i've been beating the [ __ ] out
of it